foreign
Becky
yes Becky uh where'd you grow up where
are you from originally I'm from
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania
tell me about your family
I'm the oldest of three kids I'm the
only girl I have two younger brothers
um
my mom and dad were together and married
until the day my mom passed away of
pancreatic cancer about seven years ago
sorry
um thank you
um
my brother lives in Costa Mesa works for
a mortgage company my other brother is a
head programmer for uh Disney and ESPN
he lives in Connecticut with his wife
and two kids
uh dad still here
um he lives in Pittsburgh in the house I
grew up in
and uh
um today I describe myself as definitely
um funny and outgoing
um people person I get told all the time
I have a really big heart
uh
a lot of um
funky myself enough credit you know I
know I'm smarter than uh
then I uh tell myself I am and
I could probably be in a lot better
position in life than I am right now if
I would believe in myself a little bit
more
back to your childhood what was what
were your childhood years like
great
um I mean
looking back in hindsight I mean growing
up I thought they were they were great
um my dad believed in negative
reinforcement which ended up becoming a
huge problem for me
um I've been to Disney World three times
new school clothes every year a new
backpack every field trip you know the
whole nine yards Christmas presents
loaded under the tree
but uh
I was an overweight kid and my dad's
biggest thing was
Rebecca I hope that you'll get uh tired
of hearing me yell at you and make fun
of you and you would do something about
it
you know he would criticize you or make
fun of you
well when he would get upset with me or
whatever was a lot of verbal abuse you
know that he made sure when he was mad
at me that my weight was like the main
thing he focused on
when I was 13 years old I went to one of
those like Jenny Craig diet program
things
and um
I tried to kill myself
um at one point because I was uh I
didn't think I was gonna have lost
enough weight to make my dad happy
you know I remember I went to sleep with
a note in my pocket and I was so pissed
off when I woke up the next morning and
I was so sick to my stomach you know I
just ate a bunch of pills out of the
medicine cabinet you know what I mean
and then uh
it just kind of got a little worse from
there
you know I mean I had my friends and
stuff growing up in school I graduated
high school
um it was a clash clown
uh like I said I had my friends went out
did all the prom did the whole thing but
um I used my sense of humor to basically
cover up but I was a really sad
miserable person inside
so when I graduated high school though
for some reason uh my weight dropped off
me it was like baby fat I lost like 100
pounds and um
life was a lot different you know and I
found marijuana when I was 19 it was the
first drug I ever did
and um by the time I was 20 I was hooked
on Heroin
um but uh
19's when everything changed for me I
started being a little bit more outgoing
boys started noticing me I started
making more friends you know staying at
home less and less and less and then
like I said the heroine came into play
when I was 19 and
any drug I had tried up until that point
I could put down if I wanted to or if I
didn't have the money I could you know
say no big deal man that [__] got a hold
of me and then it is
it was hell you know and that was 23
years ago
and I'm still an opiate addict
[Music]
I'm sorry fentanyl now now I'm on yeah
now we'll see being from the East Coast
our heroine is a little different than
it is here that the type of the the com
the com the way it's made up excuse me
about that how is it different
um out here it's tar it looks like a big
bottle of black gooey stuff and like
where I'm from have you ever seen
cocaine it looks like cocaine but it's
brown like a sand color and real flaky
there's been fentanyl in it for years so
um
I kind of already had a tolerance to
that or I kind of already had a feeling
for that
but uh
yeah the the fentanyl thing is kind of
scary
um
I actually was uh selling drugs whenever
the whole fentanyl thing hit the streets
you know I uh
had a really really hard time
transitioning into that and actually
stopped selling drugs because of that
um
people were dying and people weren't
being responsible with it
which people things like an oxymoron I
guess a drug addict being responsible or
a drug addict having morals and values
which I pride myself on my principles
you know but uh
yeah I'm on that now and I'm really not
looking forward to getting off of it but
eventually I know I'm gonna have to
how many years have you been on the
streets
well I'm back home in Pittsburgh
um I kind of just like ran around the
streets my my mom and dad's door was
always open to me whenever I would
trickle in after days weeks sometimes
months but I moved here about seven
years ago
and um
was running a house for transitional
living with people with disabilities and
I loved it and our landlord was
a monster
and uh one day I decided to stand up for
the house and was tired of getting bit
by bed bugs and
um you know leaky black mold and leaky
faucets and everything like that and um
I ended up getting I had withheld my
rent got served evicted in court and was
out in two weeks on my ass I don't know
how he did it
but I found myself homeless on the
streets in California
and the only thing better here than
Pittsburgh is at least it's warm here
you know but uh
it's been a learning experience
um
I thought that
all the bad stuff that has happened to
me in my life couldn't get any worse
you know until I moved here when I was
27 years old back in Pittsburgh I was um
raped by five guys in an alley
one morning I was waiting to go to work
and a kid came up and asked me what time
it was and the other one came up from
behind put a pillowcase over my head and
they dragged me into an alley
you know and I am
didn't leave my house for like a year
then I trickled out with my parents and
night terrors and the whole the whole
thing and I didn't think you could get
any worse than that until I moved here
to California so
most people go their whole life without
calling an ambulance unless it's like a
family member having a heart attack or
something nobody sees a dead body unless
it's in a funeral home
uh no one gives anybody CPR really the
statistics it's really it's rare that
someone has to give somebody CPR in my
first two years in California I found a
body
saw somebody get killed
um I've saved 12 people from overdosing
so far I'm 12 for 12.
um
it's it's
become normal and that's
really sad
you know like um
I've uh
become desensitized to a lot of things
you know
I uh lost the love of my life six months
ago
um
he uh it was a drug addict as well he
did methamphetamines and he did his with
IV
and I went to sleep one afternoon to
take a nap and when I woke up he was
dead with a needle in his arm because
his artery ruptured from the shot and he
had a heart attack and died instantly
he was 45 years old you know and um that
was that was only six months ago
and uh
you know I'm back out here on the
streets all alone with that kind of
hanging over my shoulders a little bit
you know I'm trying to use that to um
drive me to do better
and I tell people out here all the time
when they sit there and they say oh you
can't overdose on this or you can't
overdose on that and
yes you can you can overdose on anything
you know
um
why don't I go back home people ask me
that all the time
it might not be as fast-paced as it is
here
um
but the way I look at it is if I go back
home I'm still going to be a drug addict
I'm still going to be I might not be
homeless I could probably go back to my
dad's but I wouldn't even want to put
him through that at this point you know
I just
I need to do what I need to do for me
and um
I know I'm very funny I've had people
tell me that I should have got into
comedy
um I have somebody that I met fell into
my lap who's actually taking me under
his wing
who works at a comedy club also
photography is a big hobby of mine
um my uh
my late other half
um
used to push me and push me and push me
to you know get get into that and um
it was kind of Bittersweet for me when
he passed away because anytime I pick up
a camera I would think of him
but I've been trying to
um instead of diving harder and harder
into drugs
and just totally desensitizing myself
I want to feel that pain of not having
him around in the pain of where I'm at
again
so I can use it this time instead of to
hold me down I can use it to
you know push me up and push me forward
and I made a promise to him that the
night I said goodbye to him I told him
that I would show him what his love and
support could do in this world you know
and I am to have someone love you the
way that you never thought possible no
matter what your flaws are
and you know it it can really help you
overcome anything you know and that's
where I'm at right now in my life I used
to sit at night
and think about all the bad stuff I've
seen and all the stuff that's happened
to me and
I used to think something was wrong with
me because after that happened to me in
that alley
I thought damn most women would probably
kill themselves or kill somebody or
would never leave their house again
and I thought something was wrong with
me because it didn't do that to me
you know but um
there's nothing wrong with me
you know I'm a very strong person and
I've made some mistakes in my life and I
still make poor choices and bad
decisions on a daily but at the end of
the day I can look in the mirror and be
okay with me you know and I can sleep at
night knowing that I have another day
ahead of me you know I just uh
I gotta keep thinking like that and not
allow you know that monkey on my back to
keep pulling me down
what emotions do you go through living
you're on the street right
yeah I um when I met uh my other half
Eric
um
we were kind of both on the streets
somewhat um and uh
we were together almost three years and
we got off the streets you know he he
was working and I was you know we were
both still using but he was working I
was holding down the home front you know
things were were going okay you know and
um I guess I got too comfortable
but uh when I lost him it only took
three weeks for me to lose the place we
were staying at and his truck
which was everything and I found myself
back out here yeah
no we um we were in an RV
we had purchased a small RV from a
friend of his it was in really good
condition
um we kind of had it hidden off so
nobody knew where we were and it was
like our house you know he went to work
every day and I did what I did and came
home to each other at night you know and
it was really nice but where do you stay
right now
um right now wherever I can
you know
um sometimes at night I'll sleep in a
bus stop because it's you know it's
light
you know I woke up two weeks ago to a
guy grabbing my chest in my sleep I was
sitting in a bus stop like literally I
opened up my eyes and this guy was
feeling me up at the bus stop you know
and then I kicked him
and he called the police and told the
police that I assaulted him
you know and uh I I couldn't believe the
audacity of these people they I just I
mean I guess people I guess they're
everywhere it just seems like La people
were like a little bit more they they
just a little bit more uh nerve I guess
we'll say but um
I I do have a couple people in my life
that um
have places to live so I go when I
shower there and I'll rest there during
the day but for the most part I'm on my
own
you know and I just try to stay as safe
as possible with Carrie mace I have a
knife several knives
um
like everything I own fits into a
backpack
yeah personally how does this affect you
emotionally
my pet my parents didn't raise me live
like this
um
I know that I'm not
thank you I know that I'm not a stupid
person
I know that
I have a lot of good qualities I know
that
I can be so much more than I am right
now
and I just 23 years I've been doing
opiates 23 years
that's more than half of my life
you know and uh where has it gotten me
yeah um I've met some some some
different people I've met some good
people
um and you know I I met the love of my
life
um that getting added in with the whole
whole you know drug using has been
really difficult
um
there's not a day goes by that I don't
think of him actually probably about a
minute that goes by but I don't think of
him
and uh
if I can have one wish it would be
to go back to that day
in October of 99
when I picked up that joint
and I would have said no like I had been
saying for years before that
you know
not even just know the heroine I just
wish I would have said no to all of it
and then I would have came to California
and found and found Eric sooner than
later
but uh
this life sucks man it does it's
horrible
I remember being at the bus stop in
Chatsworth California and there were
like four or five kids standing there
and they were like making a game out of
being homeless like on the weekends they
come and kick it at the train station
like and then they go home like they
thought it was like
like some big [__] party you know and
it's anything but I have to worry about
getting raped and assaulted on a daily
basis I have to worry about if the drugs
I'm doing are gonna kill me because
their laced with something I don't know
about
you know I have to steal food to eat
I hadn't been in trouble or arrested in
over 13 years and I was so hungry I
stole food from a grocery store and got
a petty theft misdemeanor charge
you know and people were like why don't
you just you know go get clean or go do
this or go do that I wish I knew
I wish I knew because
I don't I don't
this was fun in my 20s you know I'm 42
years old
I don't want to do this anymore
but it's just like I said it's become an
it's normal I'm desensitized and it's
normal I step over people in the streets
you know like I watch people OD and
people go through their pockets and [__]
and try to stop me from from saving them
because they got into a fight with them
the day before
you know
um
relax
I don't know I just I don't know and
then this whole fentanyl thing it's
different than the heroine and medically
they don't know what they're doing and
you know it's just I don't know
I guess it's just one excuse after
another when I step back and look at
myself
what's your biggest fear now
honestly my biggest fear is
I'm gonna lose my dad
I'm gonna end up losing my dad before I
get off these [__] streets and I get
back to see him
you know my dad's 73 74 years old and uh
he's in really good health especially
when I'm not around because that's what
his blood pressure goes up
the
I just I haven't talked to my family and
[__]
I don't even know
and it's just because it's not that I
don't want to it's just because I just
I don't even know what it is
I feel like I'm bothering them you know
and I I feel like
you know my dad's my biggest supporter
he always has been even doing the drugs
and getting in trouble my dad was always
the one that was there for me and and
said and I know he always will be
but like I hear like disappointment in
his voice when I call him you know and
uh I don't like hearing that
and um
my biggest fear is that I'm gonna lose
my dad while I'm out here on these
streets with my head up my ass running
around getting high
or he's gonna get that call that I'm
that I'm gone
and I I don't want that for him
so
is there anyone in your family that had
addiction issues
um my mom was an alcoholic but we uh
I saw my mom drunk once and that's only
because I was sneaking down the steps to
get something to drink and she kind of
stumbled
in the hallway you know she didn't let
us let us see her drink she didn't let
us see her drug ever but um she got uh
sober when I was 13.
my dad didn't even smoke cigarettes he'd
have a beer or two maybe at like a
Christmas party or something
um but neither one of them did drugs uh
my middle brother
he likes to drink and my youngest
brother won't even be in the same room
with me when I smoke a cigarette
you know
um alcoholism runs in my family a lot my
mom was one of ten
um six brothers four girls they're all
drinkers you know but
they all um
they all like have their own companies
all the boys they're like construction
and cars and all that stuff like that
and then my dad was one of three
um my grandma just passed away last year
her and my grandpa were married 86 years
you know and like
oh I've never been married I don't I
don't believe in divorce and I haven't
found somebody that can put up with me
long enough to want to I don't want to
do that you know and know that I'm not
leaving them you know
so you know they're not going to be able
to get away but um
I don't know I just know one thing is
that when people ask me you know uh like
what was it like growing up or this or
that it is the truth this addiction and
and and
ours like the the games we play with
ourselves in our mind and and the way
the addiction feeds that you know stigma
on ourselves and and our perception of
ourselves like it's not just movie stars
with a lot of money that get high it's
not you know kids in foster care or you
know single mothers and and this and
that like it's it's everybody my dad
retired from the post office 35 years my
mom worked at a bank and passed away a
pancreatic cancer they were together 40
years I've stayed in the state I lived
in the same house for 35 years
you know like it
just it can hit anybody you know and uh
the only thing I can say is that you
know there is no such thing as
recreational junk use there's no such
thing as recreational Weekend Warriors
or this or that because
in my experience
anybody that thinks that way one of
those weekends is going to be a bad
weekend for them or it's going to be a
bad week and it's going to be just a
little bit more this weekend than last
weekend but they got through it
and then eventually it's just an
everyday thing and
it'll get away from you whether it's
alcohol that's legal or heroin that's
not or fentanyl or whatever it might be
you know and
as as human beings we need to help each
other and and stop putting each other
down and and
one night somebody drove down the street
and through oil all over a group of
tents and a car came behind it and lit
them on fire
wait what did that solve like nothing
you know and I understand that you know
people will have the right to their own
opinion and and how they feel but
especially here in La like homeless
homelessness is a big deal drug
addiction is a big deal
I just I don't know as a society and as
a species we suck we don't we don't lift
each other up we don't help each other
out and I'm not talking about throw
money at the problem you know a little
bit of compassion would be nice you know
and um
a little bit of support I think will go
a long way
do you know what I mean and uh
we need that we need that first we need
that from ourselves too because
I used to be my biggest fan
but now I think I'm my worst enemy
would you describe yourself as
self-destructive
uh self-sabotaging definitely
anytime something good starts happening
I always find a way to screw it up
no matter how bad I want it or you know
that appointment I need to get to and
I'm all excited and I've been talking
about it for weeks I will find a reason
I will find a way to screw it up and
then blame it on everybody but myself I
know that I know that about me there is
no wool over my eyes in regards to
myself in in that issue
um I'm really good though at helping
everybody else I'm great at making sure
people get where they need to go and
it's call it and making their
appointments and doing everything they
need to do but when it comes to me I
guess I part of me just doesn't think I
deserve that I don't think I'm worth it
because of this life I've lived for so
long you know when I lost Eric
I thought you know I obviously that that
I don't I don't think I've done anything
in my life bad enough to have had that
happen
but uh
I don't know I guess uh
people like oh [__] happens and
I know that if I wasn't living the life
like I was living then um
you know or maybe if we would have moved
like we had discussed sooner or maybe if
I wouldn't have put off doing something
he asked me to do or just whatever it
might have been
maybe he'd still be here and we would be
in a better place you know
but
I'll never know that answer at least not
until I get to the other side and can
ask him but uh
yeah I'm uh I'm really good at screwing
stuff up
what's your biggest regret
um
my biggest regret is not staying clean
the first time I got clean
you know I've probably detoxed and
kicked opiates a good 25 or 30 times and
that's no exaggeration
you know uh
and I guess actually what goes Co in
hand with that is my biggest regret is
not staying clean the first time I got
clean and not learning about myself to
love myself sooner than I did
I didn't learn to love myself till I was
about 35.
I didn't really give myself the chance
to get to know who I was and to get to
know me fully not what people wanted
from me not what I thought people wanted
to see or validate myself and what other
people thought of me to genuinely know
who I was and to love myself I didn't do
that until I was 35 and I wish I would
have did that sooner because I believe
I'd be in a lot better place because I
would have um pushed myself a lot harder
and I would have believed in myself a
lot more
[Music]
Becky what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
it's never it's never too late like it
is it's for anything and it's never too
late to um
to better yourself like it's never too
late to fix something it's never too
late like oh I should have I could have
you know the three biggest words in the
English dictionary or if can't won't
you know and um if only I did this or if
only I did that
um
there is
there's so there's no time like the
present
I understand people have kids and they
have school when they're on the streets
and they're this and they're that but
you have to believe in yourself and you
have to know that you can do it and not
care what other people think or other
people say
because in the end of the day the only
person you have is you
you know and if you can't believe in
yourself and you can't push yourself
forward and you can't better yourself no
one else is going to do it for you but
it's never too late to do that it's
never too late you can hate yourself one
day and love yourself the next
but it's up to you and it's just
it's never too late to change
you know I'm stagnant right now and uh
I'm trying to figure out why
um
but at least I'm trying to figure out
why
you know I I try to find something
positive about myself and what I what
I'm doing every day
you know instead of putting myself down
at the end of the day like way to go
Rebecca there's another night you're on
the bus stop bench you know I'll sit and
think like well you know you're on the
bench but at least you got your laundry
done today you know or you know you're
on the you're sitting on this bench but
you know you went you took a shower over
at the shelter or you got some paperwork
done or whatever it is no matter how
minimal
you know I uh
I try to do that but yeah it's never
it's never too late to make a change no
matter how uncomfortable the change is
and we have to push ourselves as people
to do that
all right Becky thank you so much for
sharing your story thanks if you figure
it out and get off the streets I'll let
you know all right thank you very much